Cole is with us to start off this hour
in Fargo North Dakota hey Cole how are
you I'm doing well thanks they've done
so I've got a question for you we are
about 27 months into baby step two we've
paid off about 70 grand we still have 38
left my vehicle is coming to its last
leg paid about 1,400 bucks for it two
years ago probably put about the same
amount in and repairs since and I'm just
trying to figure out you know do I keep
putting money into repairs to eat press
pause on baby step 2 for a short period
of time to get something a little more
reliable nothing extravagant and if we
do do that you know what is the right
amount to do for that what looks like a
safe number
what's your household income we salary
were about a hundred but I work a lot of
extra designer and I work a lot of extra
projects and that's kind of what we what
have we been doing to pay off debt cool
so what's your household income last
year was 140 good good for you
way to go and you paid off thirty eight
thousand and how fast no we paid off
seventy thousand and twenty seven month
Oh seventy okay 38 whack thirty-eight
limp way to go and you're kicking it you
are kicking it well um most of the time
if you have a fourteen hundred dollar
car you don't want to spend another 1400
on it because it doesn't make it worth a
dime more when you finish right now the
thing can I keeping it alive
ya know keeping it a lot of a couple
hundred dollars at a time is where it's
better than a car payment you know
you're just limping along but if you
come up and you got a thousand-dollar
repair on a fourteen hundred dollar car
that means that car is done because we
actually because when you spend the
thousand it it doesn't make it worth
twenty four hundred it's still worth 14
hundred after you're done so you sell it
for salvage and you take that thousand
and the salvage money and a little more
money and
move on up a little bit I mean let's
face it if you bought a $3,000 car it
would be a sizable move up mm-hmm
yes stage of the game and so if you you
don't even have to put it on hold you
could just tap the brakes and have
another 1,500 the stupid car will
probably still bring 1401 it right yeah
yeah but still get a grand for it I'm
sure yeah you know put a couple grand
with it and you could do that in one
month mm-hmm so you don't you're not
even stopping you're just tapping the
brakes and you know we're just going to
get up to some basic transportation
that's what I would do if I were in your
shoes now again there's two reasons to
do this one is if you got a
thousand-dollar repair staring at you
not if you think you're going to spend a
thousand on it over the next three years
you're not going to have this car that
much longer you know because you're
going to be dead free pretty quick yeah
we've got a list of nicer things we want
to buy well I mean you'll move up in car
though at least a little bit as soon as
you're out of that and you're scheduled
to be out of debt within twelve months
yeah we're open about five six months
yeah so I mean the question is can you
make it that long on this car
and yeah well I've got an appointment
tomorrow to find out what the next
repair will be so okay well that'll tell
you I mean my opinion is if it's much
over 500 then we just go ahead and start
tap the brakes move up in car a little
bit and then once you're out of debt
move on up some more always with cash
okay what but if it's you know if it's a
couple hundred dollars and you're just
emotionally sick of this ooop D you know
suck it up drive it five more months and
get finished mm-hmm
such as the problem with me is and most
people if you're like me is that you
just get sick of driving a piece of crap
it's just yes it's just emotionally
draining and it's always breaking and
it's just your stay ticked off all the
time you know I remember I don't mind I
don't mind the looks I get or anything
I'm not talking about that it's just it
doesn't run yeah exactly stupid things
broken yeah you know that it's
overheating
again you know that stupid belt came off
of it again you know I remember that
crap and it's just like Kelly this car
is a country song on wheels I mean it's
just you know what I'm saying
I remember that sense of frustration and
so if it's that kind of stuff that's
emotional more than financial sure
that's just suck it up and drive it on
three but if it's a big thing yeah go
ahead and tap the brakes move up a
little finish the game and then at the
end the game celebrate by moving up a
little bit more so you're right on track
dude way to go this is awesome you're
doing really really well hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show so you have to
break the cycle you have to flip this
thing on its head and make it behave
you've got to get so fired up and wired
up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind